[Musique]
une manucure on pourrait penser que
c'est un petit luxe une dépense
superflue
mais pour les vaches qui passent des
heures debout se faire tailler les
ongles c'est une question de santé et de
confort les producteurs laitiers sont
donc prêts à dépenser des milliers de
dollars pour ce genre de soins
[Musique]
patrick létourneau est un spécialiste de
la manucure passer des humains celle des
vaches son travail exigent des outils
hautement spécialisés comme cette cage
de contention automotrices
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il va l'installer dans une
étable de 300 vaches où elle restera
trois jours il a engagé pour l'occasion
son fils jonathan
[Musique]
en chemin on fait monter en deuxième
employé lancelot morel
ça fait 20 ans que patrick létourneau
est ailleurs de sabots ils sont environ
70 à faire ce métier au québec ce n'est
pas une profession protéger les
producteurs peuvent souvent il ya des
vétérinaires inform en 2013 un groupe de
tailleur de sabot a fondé une
association l'association des parures
dong long qui offre une certification
le vétérinaire qui se sont associés à ce
prix qui ont parrainé avec la formation
on a des rencontres régulières sur
l'identification des maisons pour ça
parce que la manucure des vaches
ce n'est pas une affaire d'esthétique
mais de santé
[Musique]
la cage de contention c'est patrick lui
même qui l'a conçu
ça a pris 2,20 de mise au point de
taponnage bien douce line factor us line
par pat ya de l'islam pour les grappes
de ben laden
elle permet de travailler debout et
droit
la vache n'est pas couché sur le côté
comme c'est souvent le cas avec d'autres
cage de contention sauf c'est plus
ergonomique et pour l'arracher pour moi
car j'ai la patte droite comme sauvage
est capable de balancer plus facilement
les talons un autre des outils
essentiels à la manucure des vaches
c'est la barrière
[Musique]
il faut faire une sorte d'entonnoir pour
que les animaux se présente un an
[Musique]
mais l'outil le plus étonnant pour la
manucure de voici
en guise de lyme on utilise une meuleuse
électrique
une meule qui est assez agressif sur un
port tout petit en titanium avec dépassé
au carbure aux posters m'endormir il
faut pas se réveiller trop la veille
parce que c'est vraiment dangereux à 3
le travail avance rondement le vent
chercher les vaches les autres tailles
les sabots ya un avantage dans le fait
d'exécuter une attaque rapidement c'est
qu'on est moins longtemps dans les
tables on dérange moins l'auteur c'est
la première fois que patrick vié dans
cette ferme
il ne sait pas trop à quoi s'attendre la
dermatite digital c'est inquiétant
d'italie le nom commun qui est une
bactérie qui est assez virulente qui se
propage qui contagieux si on s'en occupe
pas à se déploie que ça peut devenir
assez gros puis ça affecte les vaches
beaucoup ils peuvent se mettent à bois
tenue
c'est une maladie très commune qui se
répand vite dans une étable où les
vaches sont libres d'aller et venir
comme ici dans une terre va tâcher tu
peux ne pas en avoir du tout dans une
situation limite à nos problèmes en
quelque 80% des vaches sont porteuses
c'est l'opposé que ça va éclore mais ils
vont être portés cette fraude suggèrent
tout le temps
c'est très douloureux pour la vache elle
marche - se nourrit - et donne moins de
lait la dermatite digital ce contrôle
par des bains de pieds ont fait passer
les vaches dans un bac contenant une
solution anti microbienne
si ça paraît pas à ce match
quand la maladie est déjà visible on
applique un onguent et on est un bandage
au cours de la journée
patrick et jonathan verront quelques
autres anomalies
[Applaudissements]
qui ont une hyperplasie qui est comme
une excroissance entre les deux onglets
c'est pas douloureux mais c'est un peu
est une porte ouverte pour la dermatite
dit m
[Musique]
mais la plupart du temps le travail
consiste simplement à remettre le sabot
droit parce que comme nos ongles les
sabots pousse continuellement les vaches
les us en marchant mais pas toujours
assez ni toujours de façon égale ça
dépend du plancher cette étable par
exemple vient d'être réaménagé on n'est
pas assez du caoutchouc au sable et au
béton il y a quelques mois ce qui va
changer l'état des sabots le sort va
permettre une jeune il ya telle somme
toute peu désolé c'est lui qui permet
l'usure des onguents
l'éleveur avait l'habitude de faire
venir un tailleur de sabots trois fois
par année
à l'avenir ce sera peut-être deux la
taille des sabots par un professionnel
comme patrick coûte de 15 à 20 dollars
par vache pour un troupeau de cette
taille c'est au moins 5000 $ par visite
c'est pas un gros coup ce sens contre le
confort de l'animal puis quesque avons
ordonné à faire
malgré le côté technique de son travail
lepareur dont blond est un observateur
privilégié de la santé des vaches il
peut donner son avis sur la façon de
gérer le troupeau par exemple tellement
conseiller plus de pression autour d'eux
au devant des cas c'est vraiment
difficile mais il considère non nos
points de vue qu'on nous écoute
l'expérience l'amène à faire des
constats qui ne sont pas toujours
évident pour l'éleveur
patrick a observé par exemple qu'il peut
y avoir un lien entre l'alimentation des
vaches et la santé de leurs pieds carrés
un problème au niveau de la plage et
axel dans la slaj un attelage de
roulement mais là on va voir des corps -
solde des usa et qui vont sortir
des fois c'est ça décape la corne des
cartes
comme d'autres par heure patrick
létourneau fait même un suivi par
ordinateur de chacune des pattes de
chaque vache 12
seulement ce l'extérieur grave voilà ce
qui est précieux pour l'éleveur civile
peut reculer dans l'ordinateur et 7
bachelot l'année passée la fois d'avant
est-ce qu'elle avait une lésion points
[Musique]
l'ordinateur sert même de lien entre la
ferme et la science si l'agriculteur
accepte les paroles peuvent envoyer leur
donner un système centralisé qui permet
de suivre l'état de santé des sabots des
vaches à travers le québec
les travaux de recherche ont été
entrepris à partir de ces renseignements
[Musique]
le par heure donc l'eau n'est ni un
agronome ni un vétérinaire
mais son travail devient de plus en plus
un élément clé de la gestion des
troupeaux laitiers
[Musique]